Nếu người mềm tạm tạm mùi hai nhanh thành hành hình khu trong 3 năm, không ăn phường viên châu,
khi phố cình thơ, đến hành kinh trà đồ sức hoạt động của quán khá rau kê chỉ tại năm trên địa bản phương.
Tại đây, lực lượng không ăn phát hiện tại phòng viên số sau có mùi bà đối tượng,
trong đó có một đối tượng đối lệ ra trên vui hai tùi zip trong suốt khu mồn nếm số nếng.
đến hành kinh trà bên trong hai tùi zip có chứ tinh kể giắn mổ chắng và sau viên nếng, đối tượng hai làm mà tui.
Qua ti đối tượng dự tượng dự tình với chức mà tui, tức tục kiểm tra tại phòng viên số mùi bà có năm đối tượng.
Phát hiện trên bản nơi các đối tượng đang ngồi có một dễ xử mổ chắng, đến trên có dính nhiều chức mổ chắng,
một tơ tiền mỉnh giá mùi gian đồng, một thành dựng mô tơ tiền mỉnh giá mì nhìn đồng quấn trònh thành ổ hút được của định.
Bởi bao đồ lọc túc là, các đối tượng hai là chức mà tui và dụ cụ mạc đối tượng vào dụ dụng mà tui.
Lực lượng làm những vụ tiếp tục kiểm tra su quen và hiện thêm tại hộp dự lựa dụ dụ dụ dụ dụ dụng dụng dụng dụng mò,
bên trong chứ tình tây dắn mổ chắng vào bu vinh nếng, các đối tượng thử nhận là mà tui.
Tên nhành, cả năm đối tượng đối tượng đối tượng tiền với chức mà tui.
Công ăn phương viến châu tin hành lập đi bản bắt người phản tự của tăng đối tượng có linh quan và đưa về chủ sở công ăn phường sắp mình là nó.
Sẽ thế vụ việc có tình rất nghiên trọng, nhiều tình tiếp phúc cạc, đại tám buổi đất ăn, phó giám đốc, tui chừng cơ quan cạnh rất đối trà.
Công ăn tình phố cần thơ chức tiếp chỉ đạo các đơn vị nghiệp bụt thuộc công ăn thành phố khẩn chương trình khai các biệt pháp nghiệp bụt tiếp tục đối trà mở giọc.
Sự lý các đối tượng theo quy định của pháp lật.